hey guys it's vadim with max tech and as
you already know apple broke the tech
side of the internet with the new 14 and
16-inch macbook pros with their
controversial thick boy redesign and of
course the notch that nobody was
expecting but in reality the real
shocker comes down to apple's new m1 pro
and m1 max chips which are blowing the
minds of basically everyone in the
engineering world and the tech space in
general for various different reasons
which i'm gonna dive deep into in this
video which is a hundred percent focused
on these new chips so what i'm gonna do
is explain everything you need to know
about them including how they work and
what makes them so special compared to
any other computer chip on the market so
without further ado let's get right into
the basics the m1 pro chip is basically
a souped-up version of the m1 chip from
last year packing in twice the number of
performance cores and gpu cores while
ditching two of the efficiency cores
giving us a 10 core cpu and 16 core gpu
on the m1 pro and speaking of those
cores the apple tree on twitter who by
the way wrote this wonderful article has
confirmed that the new chips are in fact
based directly on the course from the m1
chip and if that sounds obvious i
previously speculated that apple would
base these cores on the new ones in the
iphone 13s a15 chip since basically all
of those cores are faster across the
board than the cores in the m1 but as
you can see apple rated the m1 pro's gpu
cores at 5.2 teraflops of performance
which is exactly double the performance
of the m1's 2.6 teraflops confirming
that they're the same exact course on
top of that i speculated that apple
would pack in the a15 chips faster
neural engine that can run over 15
trillion operations per second but nope
apple showed that the one in the m1 pro
is using the m1 chip snurl engine with
11 t-flops of performance so this
basically confirms a few of the other
details about the m1 pro and m1 max
chaps we know that they're not built on
the latest five nanometer plus process
node from tsmc it's just the regular
five nanometer and we also know that the
video encoders and decoders are most
likely identical to the ones in the
regular m1 chat but thankfully apple did
toss in some brand new prores encoders
and decoders which is by the way a world
first from apple no other computer on
the market can do this not even the mac
pro with the dedicated afterburner card
since it can only decode prores now
going back to the chip it of course
packs dedicated thunderbolt 4
controllers right inside of the chip
package as well as many other things
like the secure enclave for security an
image signal processor for the webcam
dedicated caches machine learning
accelerators and more but let's go ahead
and dig deeper into the m1 pro chip by
referring to an antex article on this
topic where andre provided a labeled
graphic of the chip itself
here he pointed out that apple is now
using two blocks of slc cache which
serves the entire chip to amplify
bandwidth reduce latency and improve
power efficiency and apparently this new
chip looks like it's using double the
amount of slc cache 32 megabytes
compared to 16 on the m1 chip now as far
as the ram apple is using unified memory
which is making these chips extremely
special so let me explain how it all
works traditional ram that you find in
many x86 based computers is always
separated from the main cpu and gpu
chips which adds extra latency since
data that needs processing has to travel
through electrical circuits in the main
logic board so to perform a graphically
based task the cpu has to copy data to
the ram and then that data gets copied
to the gpu for processing and once it's
finished the data gets copied back to
the ram again and then copied from the
ram to the cpu so that it can do its
part of the processing before repeating
the cycle all over again and again but
with apple's chips the memory is built
directly into the main package with the
cpu and the gpu and since it's unified
memory both the cpu and the gpu can have
access and work on the data at the same
time without having to copy it back and
forth and with greatly reduced latency
since it's all right there in one
package so to make this as simple as
possible imagine that there are two
painters one is called the cpu sitting
over here and one is called the gpu over
here and they have a single canvas in
the middle for them to paint and work on
it they have to hand it back and forth
to basically process and finish up the
painting but with apple's unified memory
the cpu sitting right here and the gpu
is also right here and they're both
painting on the canvas at the same time
so as you can see in this representation
of the m1 pro chip you have a dedicated
ram chip on each side of the m1 pro and
each ram chip also has its own dedicated
128-bit memory bus for that data to
travel through which effectively means
that the m1 pro has a 256-bit memory bus
which allows up to 200 gigabytes per
second of memory bandwidth which is
extremely impressive and based on
andre's calculations this means that the
ram and the m1 pro is most likely lp
ddr5 ram that runs at up to around
6400 megahertz which is much faster than
the 4266 megahertz ram and the original
m1 but making it even better the way
that apple set all of it up means that
the ram operates through 16 channels
eight channels on the left side and
eight on the right side which is
something that's completely unheard of
in the computer space but before i
explain why this is such a huge deal i
wanna ask you guys to hit that subscribe
button below to help us reach a million
subs before the end of the year and be
sure to use the m1 pro promo code to get
20 off on all of our merch including our
new m1 pro max sharpie edition shirt
down in the merch shelf below getting
back to those crazy 16 channels of ram
the beautiful thing is that you get the
full 16 channels regardless of whether
you choose the 16 gigabyte or 32 gig ram
option since both versions still use a
full ram chip on each side of the m1 pro
the difference is in the use of either 8
or 16 gig ram chips but now let me
explain why having 16 channel memory is
so impressive every single cpu that
intel currently sells uses dual channel
memory yes that's two channels compared
to 16 on the m1 pro so this means that
the current 2020 27 inch imac uses dual
channel memory the 2017 imac pro that i
wrote this script on uses quad channel
memory because of the pro grade xeon
chip and our fifteen thousand dollar mac
pro actually uses six channel memory and
to show you why having more channels is
so important here's a chart showing the
photo editing performance using
lightroom classic as you can see the
performance improves based on the number
of memory channels in the system and we
know this for sure because the imac pro
is actually faster than the regular imac
which doesn't make sense because the
regular imac has doubled the amount of
ram and it has faster cpu performance
than the imac pro but because of the
dual channel memory limitation it
actually ends up being slower in this
raw photo exporting test and to explain
this as practically as possible you can
think of a memory channel as a highway
connecting the ram to the cpu with only
two highways there is going to be a lot
of traffic when moving a lot of vehicles
or data back and forth that's why moving
up to four highways or channels on the
imac pro improved performance despite
actually having a slower cpu since it
freed up all of that traffic and then of
course it got even better with the mac
pros 6 channel memory so now you can
understand why having 16 channels on the
m1 pro chip is such a big deal but wait
there's more and get ready for this
because i'm about to blow your mind
everything i just mentioned was for the
base m1 pro chip so now let's venture
into the more expensive m1 max this chip
is much larger as you can see in this
image being roughly 75 bigger than the
m1 pro and three and a half times bigger
than the original m1 chip so what this
m1 max chip does is it basically doubles
up on many of the components found in
the m1 pro
including double the gpu cores to make a
32 core gpu double the slc cache to make
64 megabytes of cash which can be used
by the entire chip
double the number of ram chips as you
can see in this graph four of them and
double the number of memory buses to
support those ram chips making for an
incredible 512-bit memory interface
which gives the chip up to 400 gigabytes
per second of memory bandwidth and the
craziest thing of all is that the number
of memory channels is once again doubled
yes the m1 max ship regardless of the
amount of ram or gpu cores that you pay
for has 32 channel memory now if that
didn't blow your mind i don't know what
else will because what apple has
achieved is literally an engineering
masterpiece since even the latest epic
server chips from amd are still limited
to just 8 memory channels and to put the
final cherry on top because of the
unified memory architecture the ram is
fully accessible by the gpu meaning that
if you bought the model with 64
gigabytes of ram you essentially have up
to 64 gigs of vram for the gpu to make
use of this makes the m1 max the world's
first chip or gpu to come on the market
with more than 48 gigs of accessible
vram beating out nvidia's quadro rtx
8000 gpu which sells for fifty five
hundred dollars by itself but to give
you guys a more realistic comparison the
previous top-of-the-line 16-inch macbook
pro with the 5600m gpu came with only
eight gigs of vram and the current best
gpu in any windows laptop is the 3080
mobile with up to 16 gigs of vram so you
can see why 64 gigs of vram on the m1
max chip is mind blowing so with that
said hopefully you learned something new
about the m1 pro and m1 max chips and if
i just convince you to order one of them
you can find links to the best deals on
the new 14 and 16 inch macbook pros down
in the description below and if you
enjoyed this video go ahead and click
the circle about to subscribe because we
just ordered eight of these to test out
and make videos on so thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]